after a month of bombing Gaza Israeli
officials say they've achieved most of
their objectives one wonders if those
include shelling hospitals and UN
schools these actions that the UN has
called violations of humanitarian law
have led those on Twitter to take up the
hashtag BDS BDS is short for boycott
divestment and sanctions it's a movement
to get individuals and institutions to
withdraw their money and support from
Israel the goal being to pressure Israel
to end its illegal occupation settlement
building and attacks on Palestinians ibn
kafka tweeted I pledge that I will never
knowingly by Israeli goods until Israel
complies with international law and
recognizes Palestinian rights
hashtag BDS that means boycotting
companies linked to Israel's occupation
of Palestinian land like the ones Nancy
Castleman lists in her tweet join BDS
don't buy from McDonald's Victoria's
Secret HP SodaStream Estee Lauder Sabra
hummus Motorola Sarah Lee L'Oreal so
much for that french fry hummus and
cheesecake makeover pajama party you
were printing flyers for huh Sami
tweeted more bad news
McDonald's is high on the BDS list my
extended family nor I will be quote
loving it anymore
garnier a cosmetics company owned by
L'Oreal recently sent care packages to
the Israeli military causing Twitter
users scanner to tweet boycott Garnier
because genocide is never pretty but it
isn't just individuals taking action
it's individuals with money the Soros
fund management of billionaire investor
George Soros recently sold twenty four
point three million dollars in shares of
SodaStream a company with a factory that
operates in the occupied West Bank
Zakaria decide tweeted Soros spun drop
shares in Israel's SodaStream BDS
beginning to bite of course the killing
of civilians didn't shake SodaStream
spokeswoman scar Jo's resolved to stand
by her brands back in January she quit
Oxfam for it what are you gonna do some
people just love bubbly water more than
human rights the BDS movement is also
being taken on
by institutions banks like Nordea of
Norway pension funds like PG GM of the
Netherlands trade unions like unite in
the UK and Ireland and religious
institutions like the Presbyterian
Church USA have all divested
Presbyterians voted in June to divest
from hewlett-packard motorola and
Caterpillar companies whose products are
used by the Israeli military in their
weaponry at checkpoints and in building
settlements but not everyone approves of
BDS they even have a counter hashtag BDS
fail the jackal tweets boycott Israel
hahahahaha you can't you never can how
about tossing away your precious phones
notebooks and gadgets first so what do
you think are you down with BDS